we're in the main space of the tea house
which is his garden called space the
thinking was to make a kind of a house
where the activities of the people would
be around this garden space you would be
walking in and let's say sitting around
here having your breakfast and then the
fresh air and light would move through
the house during the whole day when we
first met the client he wanted to make a
small and simple house he also imagined
that he and his family could garden in
the house the various gardens they were
made throughout including a roof garden
made a wonderful tea scale model and
some plans and we also then thought to
make the simplest structure
I like that simple thing that in the
everyday of the inhabitants of the user
that the living in this kind of simple
but kind of very rich and it offers a
way of relating to our tropics also
always changing atmosphere because the
plants slowly grow you mean the client
is quite unique he actually really tries
and really mate and allow the plants to
grow
so the team like I said for all projects
would be the clients the engineers
contractors when we're making each
project it's of course very important
that everybody works together and
everybody works dedicatedly and
everything that's what we have the
president designer what provides a
public recognition of all our end of us
which is a great thing it also brings in
all this experienced architects or
designers which bring with them a kind
of openness and ability to imagine other
environments
my advice is always you've got to try
things and then you've got to look and
find a path for yourself this is the tea
house design of the year